[Musik]
ein großes nachrichten update von uns
hier aus der heute redaktion guten abend
98 eineinhalb prozent mit über
deutlicher mehrheit hat der grünen
parteitag heute annalena baerbock als
kanzlerkandidat in der partei bestätigt
sie kann den rückenwind für ihre
wahlkampagne die mit pannen und
rückschlägen kämpft gebrauchen
bernburg versuchte dann in ihrer rede
auch gezielt menschen außerhalb des
klassischen grünen wähler kreises
anzusprechen veränderung schaffe auch
halt mehr von patricia wiedemeier auf
ihre partei kann sie sich verlassen mit
großer mehrheit wurde annalena baerbock
zur ersten grünen kanzlerkandidaten
gewählt rückendeckung nach wochen in
denen es nur um ihre fehler ging um zu
späte meldungen von sonderzahlungen und
unregelmäßigkeiten beim lebenslauf
vielen dank für diesen rückenwind gerade
nach dem gegenwind der letzten wochen wo
wir vor allen dingen ich fehler gemacht
habe
über die ich mich tierisch geärgert
haben mit power soll es nun wieder um
inhalte gehen erneuern will sie das land
mehr tun für klimaschutz für soziale
gerechtigkeit für kinder und jugendliche
dafür braucht es jetzt eine neue
regierung die den richtigen rahmen setzt
die investiert und dafür sorgt dass sich
die anstrengungen und wagnisse lohnen
jetzt ist der moment unser land zu
erneuern und alles ist drin
die ersten reaktionen kein wunder
allesamt positiv war die rede der
kommenden kanzlerin man hat gemerkt sie
steht da sie weiß wohin es geht sie weiß
ganz genau wohin sie mit deutschland
will dieses absolut die richtige und
sie ist die beste im rennen überhaupt da
sieht man eine frau die im leben steht
die auch die erfahrung gemacht hat die
keinen politik technokratisch muss
vertritt sondern die weiß auch was
menschen bewegt der wirt selber sieht
das anscheinend ganz anders ärgert sich
über einen kleinen versprecher in ihrer
regel
dabei stärkt die grüne partei ihrem
spitzenduo auch inhaltlich den rücken
änderungen am programmentwurf wurden
fast alle abgelehnt in cornwall in
england sitzen die mächtigen der
wichtigen westlichen industrienationen
und japan zusammen tag zwei des g 7
gipfel
die staats und regierungschefs
beschlossen heute unter anderem einen
weltweiten infrastruktur plan für ärmere
länder
dabei gehe es um ein gegengewicht zu
china so genannter neuen seidenstraße
und begehen live nach cornwall zu elmar
theveßen und elmar die g7 länder machen
der welt jetzt also ein angebot mit dem
sich china konnten wollen und selbst
projekte in afrika und asien finanzieren
wie genau soll das aussehen
ja es geht um hunderte milliarden von
dollar für ein riesiges
infrastrukturprogramm für die wirtschaft
für die gesundheit für die umwelt für
digitalisierung und auch für verkehr und
das alles soll vor allen dingen
entwicklungsländern zugute kommen es
geht den g7 natürlich in erster linie
darum china und seinem seidenstraßen
projekt den wind aus den segeln zu
nehmen mit dem china seinen einfluss
rund um den globus ausbaut und die g7
knüpfen dann die bedingungen oder
knüpfen die eine bedingungen an diese
gelder eben dass die nehmer staaten die
bürger und auch die menschenrechte
einhalten
die usa zurück im club das soll dieses
treffen ja auch zeigen wie umfassend ist
denn diese neue einigkeit tatsächlich ja
die einigkeit hat heute schon ein paar
schrammen bekommen heute morgen weil
beiden trio johnson und auch makro
gemeinsam für eine sehr harte linie
gegenüber china plädiert haben man will
harte worte wählen die
menschenrechtsverletzungen chinas
anprangern zb die zwangsarbeit von der
uigurischen minderheit in china
und man will dann diesen
worten auch taten folgen lassen heute
morgen haben aber angela merkel der
italienische premier draghi und auch die
eu-spitze er auf die wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit mit china verwiesen und
der amerikanische präsident fordert
jetzt klare kante für die
abschlusserklärung am morgigen sonntag
herzlichen dank aus russland kommen
kritische worte von präsident wladimir
putin das verhältnis zwischen moskau und
washington habe einen tiefpunkt erreicht
sagt er in einem interview mit dem
amerikanischen sender nbc bezeichnete
putin den ex präsidenten donald trump
als außergewöhnliche und talentierte
person joe biden dagegen sei er ein
karriere mensch die beiden präsidenten
putin und beiden treffen sich am
mittwoch in genf
und jetzt in dieser sendung das thema
corona der aktuelle inzidenz wert bei
uns liegt bei 18,3 schauen wir uns jetzt
die impf situation in deutschland mal
ein bisschen genauer an
da wurden bisher bundesweit mehr als 60
millionen dosen verabreicht
am anfang vor allem in den impfzentren
mittlerweile wird der anteil der arzt
praxen bei den impfungen immer größer
wie lange braucht es dann die
impfzentren überhaupt noch ende
september will der bund stand jetzt die
finanzielle unterstützung für sie
streichen
klar ist die zentren sind teuer beispiel
hessen nach schätzungen der
kassenärztlichen vereinigung kostet dort
eine impfung im impfzentrum gut sieben
mal so viel wie in der arztpraxis jan
frederik fischer mit mehr dazu
stolz wurden die zentren 1 präsentiert
doch schon bald könnte für sie die
vollbremsung kommen in hessen oder
berlin soll möglichst im september
schluss sein mit den im straßen- und
auch in bremen soll bald ein zentrum
schließen andere länder hingegen wollen
sich noch nicht festlegen
der deutsche städtetag fordert deshalb
jetzt klarheit wir müssen von den
ländern jetzt die entscheidung haben ob
die impfzentren weiter betrieben werden
sollen was nicht geht ist dass wir im
september die zentren runter fahren um
sie im oktober wieder hochzufahren
schon jetzt kritisieren einige
ärzteverbände die doppelstrukturen von
impfzentren einerseits haus und
betriebsärzten andererseits und vor
allem die hohen kosten für eine spritze
im zentrum
doch noch ist es schwer abzusehen wie
sich die pandemie weiter entwickelt der
präsident der bundesärztekammer bleibt
daher zurückhaltend da die finnen zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt unvernünftig die ins
zentren zu schließen die ausgaben sind
einmal getätigten zu können im herbst
und winter aus meiner sicht gut dazu die
denn die niedergelassenen kolleginnen
und kollegen beim impfen und auf
bestimmten dann auch weiter so etwas
ob das wirklich nötig sein wird das wird
sich erst später zeigen diskussion ist
aber schon jetzt in vollem gange dann
gucken wir jetzt noch kurz auf das
wetter morgen im osten und am alpenrand
anfangs noch wolken sonst gibt es viel
sonne bei höchsttemperaturen zwischen 17
und 26 grad
und mit diesen aussichten sagen wir im
moment erst mal danke für ihr interesse
wünschen ihnen einen guten abend und
machen jetzt weiter mit unserer em
berichterstattung wir haben die
schrecklichen bilder aus kopenhagen
gerade gesehen und drückt natürlich dem
dänischen spieler christian eriksen die
daumen
jochen breyer macht hier gleich weiter
im zdf programm genannt